whatõs God's any henchman assassin
commando spy double agent mercenary or
was the truth about him you guys last
him a lot in the comments so here we go
role title
otoscope zinnia was born into a
middle-class family in vienna austria on
june the twelfth and 1908 as a student
he distinguished himself in scientific
topics and after graduating he enlisted
at the University of Vienna as an
engineering students his great passion
was fencing he joined the University
fencing team and during a match he
received the prominent scar on his cheek
known in German as a SH miss which was
then a coveted mark of bravery among
German and Austrian youth in 1931 as
Nazism was gaining popularity in Europe
Scott zany joins the Austrian Nazi Party
filling the ranks of the local version
of the paramilitary s a Brownshirts
clever ambitious and physically imposing
at six foot four that's 1.93 metres he
must have been a valued member in the
meantime he had earned his degree and
had started work as a civil engineer
[Music]
Austria had become a part of Germany
with the 1938 Anschluss so when world
war ii broke out in 1939 scores any
applied to join the veer marked but his
military career it got off to a bumpy
start when his application to join the
Luftwaffe was denied he was told that he
was too tall and too old being 31
instead he joins the SS and became an
officer cadet in Hitler's bodyguard
regiments in 1940 it's God's Annie it
was a second leftenant in the vaartha SS
his engineering skills proved useful
when he designed special ramps to blow
tanks on the ships but he also proved
his courage under fire during combat in
Holland France and the Balkans yeah he
was decorated after capturing a large
Yugoslavia of tenants Scott zany was
then transferred to the Eastern Front
after the launch of Operation Barbarossa
in June of 1941 with the second SS
Panzer Division Das Reich he was a part
of the unsuccessful siege of Moscow and
in December of 1942 now a captain
received a head wound from a piece of
shrapnel Scott Denny was awarded the
Iron Cross for bravery and then sent
home to Vienna to recuperate while there
he became fascinated with the idea of
commando operations and read all the
books about them that he could find he
then transformed those ideas into plans
for unconventional warfare which he
submitted to our headquarters and they
started to take notice his concepts they
soon reached the desk of ernst
kaltenbrunner the head of the reich
security services and successor to
reinhard heydrich still Sandy's ideas
were then passed on to general
schellenberg head of the SS Foreign
Intelligence Service his cause any and
schellenberg net and the general was so
impressed that he appointed him as
commander of the newly created vafan
sand a verb and said BV Friedan Thal SS
unit dedicated to special operations his
career as a commando leader well it had
just begun
it's cause a me and his unit they
launched into their first mission in the
summer of 1943 and that was operation
Francois the plan was to organize the
nomadic Qashqai people in Iran into an
armed guerrilla force which could serve
the German war effort because they these
paratroopers were also assigned to
disrupt the supply lines between the
Allies and the Soviets and to turn the
local population against the Allied
presence because aney parachuted into
northern Iran packed with gold and
explosives his intention was to bribe
the tribesman elders and win their
support for the mobilization of the
entire people the operation it proved to
be a failure a fellow agents Paul Ernst
Fagin Hine made a remark that as soon as
they were out of gold the Persians sold
them to the British escort Zanies next
mission it would prove to be his most
famous and spectacular success and was
Operation Oaks the rescue of benito
mussolini imprisoned after the
monarchist coup in 1943 firsts Kozeny
had to find mussolini the ex dictator
was continually moved from one hiding
place to another but the Germans
discovered him at a villa on the Isle of
La Maddalena near Sardinia this caused
any then flew over in a Heinkel 80111
bomber to take aerial photos of the
location but the plane it was shot down
by Allied fighters and crashed into the
sea scores a knee in his men they were
rescued by an Italian warship Mussolini
was moved again and the chase continued
finally its cause any tracked him down
to the campo imperatore hotel a remote
and fortified resort on Gran Sasso
Mountain in central Italy the hotel was
accessible only by funicular he
Luftwaffe general cut students and major
otter Harold Moore's a paratrooper
battalion commander came up with a
workable plan Scorsone assembled a team
of 107 commandos who had landing gliders
on the 12th of September 1943 the
gliders approached the hotel susannah
realized too late that what he thought
to be a patch of grass was rocky in
climb his glider almost crashed but he
made it out in one piece 12 minutes
later scores any had found him a Cellini
and not one person had been killed
the Fuhrer delighted wits cozy and he
awarded him the Knight's Cross as a
result he became Hitler's favorite
commando and was dubbed the most
dangerous man in Europe by the Allies
although propaganda chief dr. garbles
may have been the first to whom that
title propaganda coverage of the events
however hid the fact that most of the
planning and execution had to be
credited to score zinnias
general students and major Moors because
I stole their thunder by making sure he
would be the one escorting Mussolini to
the getaway plane in full view of the
cameras it's cause any dough should be
recognized with the stroke of genius
that ensured the red was bloodless he
had secured the cooperation of general
Selassie of the military police so that
he was actually the first one who
approached the hotel and ordered the
heavily armed military policeman to
stand down it should be noted that
footage and photos of the event showing
many of the Italian guards posing with
big smiles by Mussolini and scores any
hinting their true loyalties based on
testimonies from one of the guards
Mussolini it seemed to be the least
happy to have been rescued the next
mission force cause any was operation
long jump in November of 1943 its
ambitious goal was to kill or kidnap the
Allies big three leaders Stalin
Churchill and Roosevelt at their
strategic conference in Tehran Iran a
first group of six German operatives
landed in corn before proceeding to
Tehran on Camelback because any was
supposed to join the group with a second
team of assassins unfortunately for them
a few months earlier the operations
planner SS office of von Otto had made
friends with a veer marked leftenant in
a bar in Copenhagen blind drunk also
that spilled the beans on long jump that
left Tenon's well here was a Soviet
intelligence officer in disguise
Roosevelt and Churchill were alerted to
the plot and were kept safe at the
Soviet embassy the NKVD then seized the
six German commandos and forced them to
radios cause Annie's team that the
operation had failed to give the full
picture sources claimed that this plot
never existed it was just a clever ruse
of stalin and/or the NKVD to force the
western leaders to stay inside the
soviet embassy where the conversations
could be easily bugged the next
high-level hit commission - because any
was the capture of tito the operation
might sleep also in this case cause any
in his commandos attacked by gliders
while conventional forces engaged Tito's
partisans round his Mountain helicopters
did I say helicopters
sorry I meant headquarters in any case
the partisans resistance was fierce
stalling the pincer movement and
allowing Tito to escape Scorsone would
finally have time to shine after the
20th of July 1944 following the
attempted bombing on Hitler in his
memoir he claimed he plays an integral
part in restoring order to Berlin where
the conspirators that initiated planned
Valkyrie to topple the ridge
because any infiltrated the conspirators
base of operations and happy Valkyrie
order rescinded this was an order
intended to quell a possible kubarz had
been cleverly exploited by the
conspirators to trick German troops into
arresting loyal Nazi officials squads
Annie's actions contributed to
dissipated confusion restored
communications to führer headquarters
and prevented a possible civil war
between German troops because then he
took charge of their marked
administration until normalcy returns
again Hitler was delighted in October
1944 he dispatched him to Budapest to
lead Operation panzerfaust aka
Operation Mickey Mouse the Fuehrer was
not pleased with the Hungarian leader
Admiral horthy an uneasy ally against
the Soviet Union who was actually
pro-american and had always refused to
deport the Jewish population the Germans
got wind that he was negotiating with
the Allies and because Elliot was sent
to exact punishment school ad and his
commandos they stormed the presidential
palace seized the Admirals son rolled
him into a carpet and kidnapped him off
he was forced to negotiate and
eventually to stand down his leadership
was replaced by a puppet government
under the Arrow Cross party who was
staunchly anti-semitic
during the following 56 days an
estimated 320,000 Hungarian Jews were
sent to their deaths in the gas chambers
another hundred thousand died of
starvation or disease in December 1944
scuzz a knee launched his most infamous
mission operation greif or griffin the
goal was to capture key bridges over the
Meuse river during the Battle of the
Bulge the last German offensive in the
West because then his plan was ingenious
he selected commandos who were fluent in
English dressed them in American
uniforms and sent the behind enemy lines
in Belgium to spread panic and confusion
because Amy's men cut communication was
issued fake orders and turned around
road signs the arrogance they grew
paranoid some GIS fired on each other
while others grilled their maids about
American popular culture to identify if
they were German agents if you were
American but did not care about baseball
nor movie stars well you could see
yourself getting arrested at one point
Field Marshal Bernard Montgomery refused
to show his ID and and his car tires
shot out he was then dragged into a barn
and restrained until his identity could
be confirmed this caused a nice spread
the false rumor among his men
the real name was the assassination of
General Eisenhower headquartered in
Paris German agents captured by the
Americans confessed to this plot as a
result Eisenhower was put under virtual
arrest for his own protection
Griffin eventually failed and many
Germans were easily identified and shot
as spies
so as the Reich began to crumble schools
Amy's final involvement was with
operation werewolf this was a resistance
movement mostly composed of Hitler youth
members trained in guerilla tactics to
oppose an allied operation
it actually was a desperate propaganda
ruse by Goebbels to raise morale but
scores Amy he hijacked the plan and used
this small force to aid the escaping
Nazi high officials the Soviet NKVD
probably overestimating the size and
importance of wehrwolf killed roughly
5,000 boys aged 15 to 17 for suspected
guerrilla activity
a few days after Hitler's suicide scuzz
ne handed himself over to the Americans
he was a highly decorated well-respected
military professional but his directive
for his men to wear American uniforms
got him in a lot of trouble this was
considered a war crime and he was put on
trial in 1947 luckily for him the
escaped execution when British SOE
operatives confirms that they wore
German uniforms during the war but he
answer answer on other charges before he
could be prosecuted those cause any
escapes from the POWs camp with the help
of two SS men dressed as American
military police he later claims this was
a plan of the OSS the CIA's predecessor
the author his freedom in return for his
services but was this true
[Music]
scuzzy knee first hit in bavaria then
salzburg and finally Spain where he
cooperated with Francisco Franco's
military and intelligence services he
was Dean Anza fide in absentia by a
German Court in 1952 but was still a
person of interest for the famed
Austrian Nazi hunter Simon Winston Thal
in any case he could leads an open life
he even had a young wife he had several
legitimate activities as well an
engineering firm an import-export
business and mercenary security company
but apparently he had time for other
endeavors he founded a neo-nazi group
called sedate the spanish circle of
friends of europe and is rumored to have
smuggled ex-nazis to south america it is
said that he particularly took them to
Argentina where he served briefly as a
military adviser to Juan Peron most
notably he was bodyguard to Evita there
are even rumors that they were having an
affair in the late 1950s he became
fixated with gaining entry to the UK
this may be the reason why in 1959 Otto
Skorzeny bought a farm in County Kildare
Ireland he was granted temporary visas
to stay on Islands but state records
mentioned his indignation at the
continual refusal of the British
authorities to allow em entry into the
UK newspaper reports in the 1960s give
another version his farm in Ireland was
a place where fleeing Nazis could hide
but no evidence was found to
substantiate this claim maybe he just
really liked the Guinness
and now for something truly puzzling as
an escaped former SS officer who had
indirectly contributed the deportation
of Hungarian Jews SCO's Amy knew very
well that his name was on the top of the
list of Nazi unto Simon Wiesenthal and
so he was the first one to be surprised
when agents of the Mossad Israeli
intelligence came to recruit him early
1962 because Eddie was having some
drinks at a bar in Madrid with his wife
the two befriended a now they young a
couple of German tourists Stuart just
been robbed since we're looking for some
help
the two couples went on drinking and
apparently flirting until the Scots
Amy's invited them to their villa just
when things started to kick off well
they did kick off but in another way
skills any pulled a gun on a couple I
know who you are and why you were here
you are Mossad and you've come here to
kill me the man replies if we had come
to kill you you would have been dead
weeks ago the two operatives they were
there to office cause any a deal they
needed his services and would pay
handsomely it's cause Amy though he was
not interested in money what he wanted
was to be removed from Wiesenthal's list
the Mossad agents they agreed because
any was flown to Tel Aviv where he met
Mossad agent Jaron and he was also
Viennese but as a Jew he had lost all of
his family in the camps renown took the
ex-nazi to the Holocaust Museum and
observed that he appeared respectful
SCO's amy's mission was to thwart
Egypt's rocket military program led by
Heinz Kruger German scientist formerly
associated with Verna Braun Braun the
Austrian commander was shown a letter
from Wiesenthal accepting the removal of
his name from the list of Nazi criminals
in truth
Wiesenthal had refused and the letter
was just a Mossad forgery because any
though he kept his promise and he
delivered big time he flew to Egypt and
identified all German scientists working
for the program he then unmasked several
companies around Europe that were
secretly selling rocket components to
the Egyptians he even carried out a
campaign of intimidation against the
scientists and mailed explosive packages
prepared by the Mossad killing five
egyptian technicians one day in 1962 in
Madrid's cause any received a phone call
it was Heinz Kruger the lead scientist
of the program crook was dead scared and
was seeking SCO's alias help and
protection because any arranged to meet
him in Munich as he drove him out of
town in a white Mercedes he reassured
him that he had already hired some
bodyguards and they were driving to meet
them
they stepped out of the car and into the
woods skills a knee shot crook three
Mossad agents that took care of the body
by dissolving it in acid scores a knees
job was done he had not made a penny out
of it and he didn't know it but he was
still on Wiesenthal's list that's at
least he would be spared by the Mossad
and other intelligence famously
associated with Otto Skorzeny was the
CIA we wanted to verify this claim
directly at the source and so he did
some rummaging in the CIA's own Freedom
of Information Act search engine a brief
memo states that in 1961 schools only
had a plan to kidnap the dark asteroid
this plan had the approval of CIA
director Allen Dulles but had been
vetoed by JFK there is a caption the
memo quotes an interview released by
Scorsone to a Peruvian newspaper in 1966
knowing the man's knack for self
publicity though we weren't sure whether
we could believe it so we dug a bit
deeper on the 26th of January 1951 a
report was sent to the Secretary of
State from Germany by John J McCloy
American High Commissioner for occupying
mccloy reports that Chancellor Adenauer
was worried about the rumors of scores a
knee training the Spanish military with
u.s. covert support McCoy was not aware
of this scheme and admitted it was
worrying the CIA knew very well that's
cause any was in Spain they learned this
from a letter dated the 21st of
September 1949 sent by FBI director J
Edgar Hoover SCO's a knee had been
sighted working in Spain with a group of
Nazis with the blessings of Franco in
April 1951 the CIA was keeping tabs on
scores Annie's activities in Madrid in
particular they wrote about internal
feuding among former Nazi officers with
concerns for it to go public the memo
reads view possibility unfavorable
publicity break as results cause a NIEHS
maneuvering consider important we
clarify our interests and any US
connections fully can you explain claims
cause any connected with or supported by
US Colonel Thompson or Stimson view
categorical denial the agents ask the
question is possibly the CIC
counterintelligence core behind SCO's
aney
the CIC was a cold war-era secret
service within the u.s. army ranks
moving to the 1960s the CIA kept a close
eye on SCO's Amyas relationship to up
hill which appears to be a codename for
an organization one report states that
the chief of up hill had warned that
u.s. support for
zany would be a source of embarrassment
for the White House this is similar to
at an arts warning the picture that
emerges so far is that some US agency
possibly the CIC had some form of
contact with him German authorities have
warned the u.s. to be careful about it
but what ifs cause Amy's relationship
with other powers there is another
documents that complicates matters even
more the Adrian signs himself as hack
and shoot sir sniper will post a link in
the description so you can read it in
full but this is the gist of it at the
ends of 1943 sensing that the war would
be lost martin bormann hitler's
secretary created a secret organization
called hacker it was so exclusive that
it only had 35 members and so secretive
that even Himmler was unaware of it the
purpose of hacker was to guarantee the
survival of Nazi officials in case of
defeat to do so hacker racked up half a
billion dollars from concentration camp
victims and created hideouts in Spain
Portugal Italy Japan and Argentina but
the twist is that Soviet intelligence
had infiltrated the network apparently
by blackmailing Borman lest they
revealed the existence of hacker to
Himmler hacker remained active after the
war but here comes another twist one of
the dark and dangerous KGB figures in
hacker is the famous SS Colonel SCO's
aney who presently lives in Madrid and
also works for the Spanish intelligence
service gazania was under active
deployment in abbakumov
as early as 1942 scuzz then he was
finally recruited as a collaborator of a
Baku male in the middle of 1944 a Baku
Mao was a Soviet intelligence general
his plan was to exploit Ex Nazi
officials and agent in the Americas the
author of the document to be fair states
that it is unclear whether abbakumov
succeeded in his plans and looks for
other clues to confirm SCO's aeneas
allegiance to the KGB one of these clues
is that suppose a knee was very close to
another ex-nazi operative karl rudl the
two had been tasked with a secret
mission by the Vatican to smuggle a
Hungarian Cardinal out of prison rule
that was actually an agent of a Baku Mao
who his intentions to hijack the prison
escape and have the Cardinal shot
Rudolph smelled a rat he was probably
gonna get shot - while Abba Kumar would
leaves cause any alive and so he aborted
the operation so we should probably have
a recap about now from the 1940s to the
1960s Otto Skorzeny was a commanding for
the Nazi security services
a possible double agent for the Soviets
a member of the neo-nazi ring hacker an
agent of Franco's intelligence a hitman
for the Mossad a possible informant to
the u.s. CIC and an operative for the
Vatican so as you can probably see our
initial question of whether articles any
work for the CIA well it seems rather
irrelevant now the answer is probably
not if anything his calendar was just
simply too full to fit them in
[Music]
in his later years autos cause any he
fell ill from lung cancer on July the
5th 1975 he died in Madrid at the age of
67 he had two funerals one in Madrid and
the other and his family plot in Vienna
at both he received full Nazi honors
with veterans giving him the Nazi salute
and singing some of Hitler's favorite
songs among those presents one man stood
apart he did not join in with the Nazi
nostalgic paraphernalia but offered a
silent salute to a fellow secret agent
and fighter someone he had grown up
hating that had learned to respect that
man was Mossad agents jaren on an zits
with this strange image of an Israeli
spy at a Nazi funeral that we entered a
story an image which sums up the career
of a man who had clearly been a follower
of Nazi ideology but was ultimately
loyal only to himself and I really hope
you enjoyed that video if you did please
do hit that thumbs up button below and
don't forget to subscribe also hit that
notification bell why not then actually
find out when we put out new videos and
as always thank you for watching
[Music]